foreign
let's go to the City of Angels and talk
to Sarah what's up Sarah
hi Hi how are you good what are you
doing
um I am just hanging out with my dog
she's choosing to be
um super Restless right now of course I
like how you have personified that dog
way to go yeah he is making choices that
are
so good all right so what's up
um I'm calling because I've had a lot of
thoughts about this thing in my life and
I feel like uh when I found your show I
thought you'd be a good person to ask
and um so my thing is
I feel like I'm having a lot of trouble
coping with my singleness
and I'm just looking for some maybe some
New Perspectives some advice or
something tell me about it so I've been
single now for six years I'm 34 and
basically the whole time I've been uh
dating so and that's like only dating
through friends
um people I just meet out just you know
different different places
and it's none of them have come to
anything and I mean I'm talking like
80 dates over years like 100 I've lost
count
and
I feel like I'm starting you know I
really want a family I really want kids
and as the years are like going by I'm I
feel like I'm mourning something that I
haven't even lost yet you know
yeah I know you have you have
I think I think grief is perfect right
now
the thing you don't have is this picture
that you had created for your life
right and it's it's
um
I think we all do that where they're
like I'm gonna make a hundred thousand
bucks but I'm 35 or I'm gonna have three
kids by the time I'm like we've we
create these pictures and they kind of
come from all over the place our
experiences what our dad said our mom
said our friend said and they we create
these pictures and then you wake up and
there's this little churn
in in your body that's trying to always
solve for that picture that we got
and it's like the the
anxiety alarms really just start ringing
in louder and louder it's like you're 33
you're 34 Sarah and if you get pregnant
at 35 they drag you into the geriatric
wing and they're like all right you're a
thousand years old now yeah and right so
you have all that's nonsense but you
have all this all this this undercurrent
in your body is trying to solve for this
picture you had and
the picture changed and so I think it's
really important to sit down and and own
that reality right just choose reality
at this moment I wanted to be married I
want to be in a long-term relationship I
wanted to have one kid and another on
the way
and I don't I think that's important
is that scary
I mean it is but I think like
I think that's what's causing so much
like unhappiness with it
which is so annoying because it's not
conducive to actually like meet anyone
because you feel worse about yourself
you
um
I don't want to come off this like
desperate you know
um and then you start overthinking it
that's what anxiety is the worst man it
just spins on itself
and I I have anxiety issues like of
course so for
the last year and a half I started
taking Lexapro and it has helped I mean
it's night and day it's so much better
but you know it's
it's always still there and it's always
something I have to work on and be
um aware of and
so when it's yeah yeah so
what
most medications do
um and I don't know how long you've been
around the show but it
most medications turn the alarms way
down
if you think about it like your
kitchen's on fire
it turns the smoke alarm way down it
does not put the fire out in the
building
right right right yeah and so it does
allow you to think and to move and
actually go talk to a counselor and to
get back with your friends and start
getting back to okay I can function now
but we have to function in creating a
life that's not on fire
right
and then over time not every situation
but often the alarms go off because
there's no more smoke because it fires
out
and then you got to figure out what the
damage is and get that taken care of and
then you're on to on to the next
when you look back across 80 or 100
dates
if you had to just say one or two like
this is why this isn't working what
would that be
um I feel like what would happen is
um it was always something like three to
five dates so it was always usually get
past the first date most of the time
second date yeah usually that was like
you know we have a good time and then
third date is when I get the you know
third fourth fifth it's the um
I feel like nine times out of ten it was
them telling me that you know um
either it would tell me to my face I
mean I got the whole flu or um they
would text me or they would just stop
talking to me goes to me whatever but
one of those but we would communicate
like
I'm not interested anymore and this only
started happening like
since my last relationship ended you
know
um
I feel like I was in that relationship
for four years and
before that I feel like I I didn't
really have that much trouble but why
did that relationship end
uh he cheated on me okay
so hold on let me sit there for a second
the worst part about somebody shooting
on you I think
is not that you feel duped and stupid
and that you lose trust in somebody else
I think the most disorienting thing
about somebody cheating on you is that
you lose trust in you
foreign
how could I let this how come I didn't
see this how could I create a world
where he felt he had to whatever you
start taking all of it
and people will
lose the ability to take a firm step on
the sidewalk in front of them because
they've lost faith in themselves they
don't trust themselves anymore
and often healing is not finding it
super trustworthy new partner
it's learning to trust yourself again
and how how do I do that
you gotta own the fact that somebody
cheated on you
sit in it for a minute and grieve it not
just be pissed off and try to go like
out and solve it and oh I'm gonna
I am a good person and yeah I got duped
I did
I my worry like I I totally get what
you're saying and I think my what I was
like thinking about was that um
or the thing I was worrying about
because I have so much anxiety all the
time that
I am so hyper like looking for anything
any sign to show that they will like be
like my ex that I feel like I'm it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah and because you know what I I can't
say that there were that many that I was
like oh man that was really the love of
my life that like got got away or
something you know like but I I guess
I'm just kind of like is because people
love to say like oh you attract a
certain kind of person
um so it's like this also this worry of
like oh I'm attracting these people who
actually are gonna hurt me or feel like
they're gonna hurt me and
this is you playing control defense
after you got hurt
and this luckiest thing about healing
from hurt and relationships is the only
path forward is vulnerability
the only way
you meet somebody
who's gonna be worth your time for the
rest of your life
is for you to make yourself vulnerable
enough that they could hurt you
again
and I know that sounds insane
no I I go here waiting what you mean
it as I've gotten older like the way I
meet people like single people is mostly
online because that's just the easiest
like they're everyone's everyone's
paired up like or you know the days will
the dating cool is much smaller and I
think it feels that way it feels that
way and yeah loneliness like the
physiology of being lonely not just
romantically but with friends too and
I'd be willing to bet you money that
that's a part of this also
is you just it narrows it literally
Narrows your vision of field
to where you can only see caustic
outcomes
it makes everything very very scarce and
it makes you say things like everyone
and always and never
that's what loneliness does because your
body recognizes when you're lonely
you're in danger of being dead
and that's ancient technology right it's
old wiring and that's why you're anxious
all the time
and it sounds like if I let go right now
if I open my hands and just started
hanging out with a bunch of girlfriends
around the house
I started a bowling league for God's
sakes
I put the stupid phones away can we just
do this according to this
is the app thing working
um no no and so what if we just didn't
do that for a minute
yeah it's been on pause okay awesome but
did you fill it with something else did
you start going to poetry readings or to
gymnastics class or to jiu jitsu class
or something did you put yourself in
situations where you have to be around
new wackadoodle human beings yeah yeah I
do I try I do try I do Triads give me an
example give me an example
cause I don't believe you give me an
example I joined the gym
oh my gosh have you seen people at
Planet Fitness not in like I worked out
at Planet Fitness I know but it's not
like that
people have the craziest workouts there
listen
that's not a great place that's where
people go with their headphones on and
they judge one another
I'm talking about a place where you have
to interact with other people be on the
same team be on the same and with the
same idea be learning something new
growing together that kind of thing in
the past yeah I I have of course tons of
that it I think covet has really thrown
me off because there was a long period
of time we weren't really allowed to do
anything in groups right and especially
in La you know they they really like
things were
um closed or not functioning for a long
time and
so I think now you know
um things are really starting to like
open up again and people are meeting up
again but you know there's
but that that that's why I stopped and
that it's it's like yeah you're right I
should but but let's get back in real
quick Sarah
one year turned into two years and two
years turned into three years and now
we're going on year four
and I've been in LA
and
Down by Hollywood I've been in La
several times and it's wide open right
now
what what do you mean like you can go
you could go right now and sign up for
anything you want to go sign up for oh
right right you're right yeah but I want
you to see the common denominator here
we're not going to sign up for a cooking
class or Jiu Jitsu class or Spanish
lessons or poetry readings
and that it's just so we can try to meet
somebody
what we're gonna do is look in the
mirror and say I'm freaking Sarah and
I'm 34 and I'm awesome and I'm gonna
start doing things that I love with
other people
and some of that's going to be
uncomfortable and so that's going to be
me getting out of the house
all of it's gonna be me getting out of
the house I'm gonna put the phones down
for a bit and I'm not saying I know man
my I got family members who've been
married because they met people online
I've got some of my best friends in the
world I'm not saying that's all bad and
wrong what I'm saying is in your case
it's not working so let's try something
else and
social anxiety all the The Angst you'll
feel the only way to heal is through it
even if you go see a counselor for it
they're gonna it's gonna walk you
through exposure therapy limited doses
until your body begins to realize I'm
safe
and that guy that guy cheated on me
four years I gave that guy and I thought
he was gonna be my forever guy and he
cheated on me and now I don't even trust
me
my body doesn't trust me
and we're going to slowly practice human
relationships Again by getting back with
people and getting back with people and
it feels like I was saying earlier if
you take your hands off of the wheel
like the dry like I've got to be married
now like my clock is ticking
um it feels like if you open your hands
and relax that that feeling to I'm just
gonna make Sarah the most awesome person
who's ever lived and I'm gonna be
generous and kind and fun and I'm gonna
go do fun fun stuff
it feels like then I'm never gonna meet
the guy
but the data would say in your world
those other things haven't worked so
let's try something completely different
that's going to create the life that
Sarah wants to live at this point does
that make sense
can I tell you something
there's not something wrong with you
you're not all screwed up or broken or
messed up or somehow dysfunctional
foreign
that guy hurt you
I just the way like I grew up I think
like
I you know I think it was that thing
I was attracted to someone who was gonna
hurt me like and I ignored all the signs
um and you know until it happened or I
found out it happened and
um so I feel like I already had trouble
trusting myself and then
you know having that happen it's like
you know I was already trying to repair
something and it just got more broken
and and you hear that line
um it's not a line it's actually true
that we marry our unfinished business
if we had a dad that doesn't talk to us
we're gonna find a guy who doesn't talk
to us so we can get that guy to talk to
us and so we can finally close that Loop
the only problem is that guy doesn't
talk to us either
and our bodies start hollering and
screaming at us
so when you hear me say you have to
practice something new you've got to do
something new
you have to teach your body
over time
dad didn't talk to me because something
was wrong with him not me
dad would forget to pick me up at school
and I would sit out there until five or
six o'clock at night
because he was too busy not because I
was unworthy
and you've got to teach your body that
your new relationships aren't for
solving Old Wounds they're for creating
a life that you want to live moving
forward
when you can get there it's a powerful
powerful reframing physiologically
psychologically spiritually the whole
kitten caboodle
and you can move forward in a whole new
trajectory
so my challenge to use this Sarah don't
give up on Sarah Sarah's pretty awesome
Sarah's been through it Sarah probably
could spend some time with the counselor
I think that'd be important and on the
line I'm missing you a copy of own your
past change your future my book like and
that's it's just what I'm talking about
here this stuff happened
what are we gonna do next
and then I want you to be serious about
writing down here's what I want in this
next season for 2023 I'm Gonna Learn
kickboxing I'm Gonna Learn
uh I don't know how to roll sushi rolls
I don't know what you're gonna do in Los
Angeles but I'm gonna take a puppetry
class whatever I'm gonna do those things
and I'm going to become the best version
of me I can be and I'm going to open my
hands up
because that's the only way somebody
else can slide their hand in a whole
mine as if it's open not if it's
clinched up and by the way I threw some
shade at 24 Hour Fitness for Planet
Fitness whichever one I worked out there
it's fine those places are great but
dude
some of those workouts people are doing
there in incredible